so the the sort of the classic symbol
that indicates the the uncertainty in
any scientific measurement is plus or
minus it's a plus sign over the top of a
minus sign and it's used basically to
indicate the uncertainty so if you make
a measurement and you say it's 10 plus
or minus 1 you're saying well it my best
guess is it's 10 but it could be 9 or it
could be 11 and really in science any
measurement you make there has to be a
measurement of uncertainty - you really
can't just give a number it has to be
you know how well did you measure that
number because otherwise there's no way
of using it you've no way of knowing if
somebody else goes and measures it and
gets a different number you want to say
well is there you know is one or one of
you wrong or you just within the
uncertainty one person might measure it
is 10 and the other person might measure
it is 12 all these different numbers
should we be worrying and until you
quote an error bar on it you really
haven't actually defined what the
measurement is that you actually made
it's far from trivial thing to do it's
this classic case that there are known
unknowns and they're unknown unknowns
but the known unknowns are things that
are just kind of you know things that
you knew were there and your
experimental apparatus I could only
measure this to this accuracy my ruler
wasn't that good all those kinds of
things so where you actually have some
finite precision in your measurement and
those you can usually estimate
reasonably well because you know what
your experimental apparatus is you can
make a whole series of measurements for
example and see how different the
answers come out every time that gives
you a pretty good measure on the
uncertainty but then there are the
unknown unknowns which are kind of also
known as often the systematic errors
things which are kind of buried so deep
in the whole thing that you actually
have no way of knowing what they are and
they're more problematical so for
example one of my one of my favorite
plots in astronomy is a plot of how far
the Sun is from the center of a galaxy
and the unit that astronomers usually
use to measure this is a thing called
kiloparsecs thousands of PASOK's and
when I started in astronomy the answer
was 15 kilo positive air abouts the
answer was 15 kiloparsecs we were 15
kiloparsecs away from the center but if
you follow the literature over time you
find that that number went down and down
and down
so by 1990s we were about eight
kiloparsecs from the center of the
galaxy now this wasn't because we moved
it wasn't because we were getting close
to the center of the galaxy just because
the measurements were changing with time
but the interesting thing was that at
any given moment so in the you know in
1985 if you'd asked all astronomers how
far away are we from the center of the
galaxy they would all have quote
you answer with a very small error bar
because actually the random errors these
these uncertainties that we know about
actually we're getting quite small and
they all agree with each other but
actually they were all wrong and that's
because everybody had the same sort of
systematic calibration in there maybe
there was some very basic calibration
that had gone into it where there was
something that was just something wrong
in the calculation and so there's this
the the strange effects that you can
have these big systematic errors that
don't behave the same way as random
errors things don't just bounce around
in a random way between one measurement
and another you can have everybody all
wrong in the same direction one way or
the other and sort of more worrying is
something that scientists like to try
and kind of push under the carpet
because we're a bit embarrassed about it
is the psychology in this as well in
that if you know in 1985 I made a
measurement of the distance to the
center of the galaxy when everyone else
said it was 10 kiloparsecs and I got an
answer that said it was 7 kiloparsecs
I'd have thought well I must have done
something wrong and I'd have quietly
stuck in a filing cabinet somewhere I
forgot about it
whereas if I got an answer that sort of
agreed with the consensus and got the
same answer as everybody else I'd
probably gone out and published it and
say look I've come up with this clever
new way of doing it and look I get the
right answer so there's also in this
error process that's actually psychology
as I say scientists are very
uncomfortable about this because we like
to have this idea that what we're doing
is kind of a projective and above such
things but actually there is a lot of
sort of human interaction and psychology
in the way we do science as well which
can also introduce errors into into such
measurements if a measurement is really
really uncertain so it's something so
bad that you're not even prepared to say
what it might be plus or minus then the
convention in science actually I'm not
sure if it's all across all of science
it's certainly the case in astronomy is
you put a colon after so if you said
measured something and it came out as 15
kiloparsecs but you were you see it was
officially dodgy measurement you
couldn't even say whether it was 15 plus
or minus 1 or 15 plus or minus 10 but
nonetheless you thought you know it
might be an interesting number you put
15 colon kiloparsecs